[Musique]
bah
vu à thé pouvoir bien jouer bébé
[Musique]
sherlock holmes se faire dans les
français ou des nains de jardin à part
pour celui que vous venez de cassis dans
un sherlock noces
vous savez ce que font les nains de
jardin quand nous avons le dos tourné
la voie est libre vous pensez qu'ils
passent leur temps à s'amuser
nous avons toute la vie devant nous fini
tout le monde à sa place que tout va
bien dans le meilleur des mondes et non
quand les nains de jardin disparaissent
juliette
ils ont tous disparu il n'y en a qu'un
qui peut mener l enquête
charlotte fervent défenseur des nains de
jardin non fervent défenseur
à part pour celui que vous venez de
casser quasi casser le 11 avril
watson
un terrible danger menace ses nains de
jardin par le réalisateur de kung fu
panda
quitte à personne ils veulent nous
réduire en miettes tous avant demain
soir l'un d'eux trois parties nous
devons traverser le fleuve
il nous faut une bassine ou un bol on
n'a pas de bol sherlock pour une
incroyable aventure
mais ni le prochain a dit se trouve dans
le parc
suivez la ligne bleue tracée au sol
jusqu'à la punaise rouge géante
attention une punaise ça pique
nous devons être très discrets alors 6-2
en avant stop
j'ai dit stop je n'ai pas l'habitude
d'être le postérieur d'un écureuil nous
sommes repérés
sherlock qui n'ont aucun écureuils de se
trémousse de la sorte banking fait plus
une démonstration au cinéma le 11 avril
[Musique]
vous avez remarqué que dès votre
naissance les gens croient tout savoir
sur vous quand vous voyez vous dites les
gros où il fait peur et avec moi c'est
un peu plus compliqué j'ai pas dit tu es
pardon à dieu sinon avait une vie
parfaite s'est il senti garçons jusqu'au
jour où je les laisse au total changé
par les créateurs de rio et de l'âge de
glace
la compagnie nouveau mais moi j'ai pas
peur de toi tu parles à ses fesses là tu
parles à mais c'est ce grand père c'est
l'avantagé de vous je m'appelle una moi
c'est dos et moi c'est courtier est
passé outre s il faut que je rentre chez
moi
[Musique]
je le coton fou attention aux spoilers
tu peux parti shas pays j'aimerais pas
être toi tu auras mon gré dehors il ya
des endroits où on n'est pas maltraité
juste pour ce qu'on est
je vais partir d'ici et je laisserai
personne derrière moi c'est un plan
génial
à la maison les avis qui pourrait lui
aussi attrapé
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
noël offrez vous la plus énorme des
aventures
la page
[Applaudissements]
c'est du gâteau
j'adore les gâteaux ferdinand
[Musique]
voici les clés de votre chambre je vous
souhaite un horrible séjour
[Musique]
j'ai dit que tout pouvait rester avec
moi tant que tu étais bien sage
j'oubliais j'ai besoin de vacances
l'année prochaine
préparez vous
prendre des vacances monstrueuse
une croix ciel
non non non non non non non
attention soyez stadiste il ya des
activités à gogo une piscine olympique
plus faire volonté un spa de luxe
ouais c'est très impressionnant c'est
comme un hôtel qui flotte sur l'eau
ok papa merci beaucoup
[Musique]
vive à vomir
bien dans tes gironde viendra t dépêche
toi pourquoi comme entendent je sais ne
devrait pas aimer la musique mais c'est
plus fort que moi j'ai la musique dans
son ouvrage sera même les musiciens sont
égoïstes et responsable on a dit plus de
musique tu va écouter ta famille pense
que nous sommes les seuls au mexique a
détesté la musique et à des los muertos
a commencé ce soir on reste en famille
des ancêtres serons toujours là pour te
guider si seulement quelqu'un pouvait
m'aider à accomplir mon rêve
[Musique]
je dois rester avec moi on ne sait pas
où on est
[Musique]
oui elle mêle da toujours aussi belge
est que chaque chien alors séparé vous
êtes tous vraiment la bienvenue
rien à déclarer est bien comme à dire
ici
c'est l'enfant vivant on regarde ta main
je vais bien inscrits
tu dois rentrer chez toi avant le lever
du soleil le dd si vous allez c'est moi
google sort
deux virgin et ya une chose qui fait
qu'ils me sens différent et je ne savais
pas d'où ça venait on ne peut pas renier
sa véritable destinée
à toi maintenant de faire à chaud
[Musique]
tu fais je marche comme un squelette
pour passer inaperçu jamais vu un
squelette qui est cette démarche vous
marcher comme ça pas du tout tu arrêtes
1 dans ma famille on n'est pas toujours
d'accord sur tout mais on reste soudé
rien n'est plus important que ce que
vous aimez
[Musique]
je vous trouve en pleine forme pour
battre avec monsieur parle ici
ballington tu prends chick et l'âge
exactement 80 80 au moins un petit ours
jeter un oeil l'animal est de retour au
molard dans une nouvelle grande aventure
dans un geste très tôt vous mais c'est
pas moi le voleur ce noël paix tu nous
donnes revient au cinéma que la chasse
quand excusez moi mais c'est la course
touché un mot sur la nourriture on
pourrait ajouter un peu de sauce
quelqu'un c'est ce qui marche pour le
ketch à paddington n'hésiterai pas une
seconde il a nous avait besoin d'être
fait partie de la famille où vas-tu
comme [ __ ] saint-vital va d'abord
paddington s'est déjà fait de ces
gentils zappi que vous voulez bien nous
excuser mans on ne peut pas se fier à
des types comme eux mais regarde les
enfin regarde ce grand pas - barbu qui
est au milieu il doit avoir à peine deux
neurones dans sa boîte crânienne
on vous entend toujours badminton 2 au
cinéma du 6 décembre